un bon soir françois mary merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france avant
d'entrer dans le détail 1 globalement
est ce que ces annonces de jean castex
sont à la hauteur de vos attentes
c'est très difficile de qualifier
d'abord nos attentes
et puis là la qualité des annonces moi
ce que je voudrais dire sur le court
extrait que vous avez donnée de la
conférence de presse du premier ministre
c'est qu'une prime évidemment c'est
toujours une bonne chose et c'est
toujours bon à prendre mais s'agissant
des métiers les moins bien valorisés ont
dû casser notre analyse à nous les
syndicats évidemment ça ne règle rien ça
ne règle rien parce que la question qui
est posée pour ces emplois là comme on
appelle les emplois de la deuxième ligne
bien c'est la valorisation salariale
bien entendu ce sont souvent des emplois
très précaire mais aux conditions de
travail de vie très très difficile et
c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit il faut
que dans des branches qui les
représentent bien aujourd'hui on se
saisisse du dossier qu'on regarde
comment faire évoluer ses rémunérations
qui sont trop faibles et comment rendre
attractif ces emplois verts qui ne
trouve pas preneur aujourd'hui et c'est
bien normal parce que quand on n'emploie
pas preneur c'est que l'emploi n'est pas
suffisamment valorisé la priorité aux
jeunes
c'est une bonne chose pour vous les
annonces étaient tout de même suffisant
vous venez de le dire mais tout de même
les bienvenus justement en faveur de
cette jeunesse qui souffre plus que
jamais oui tout ce qui est tout ce qui
est proposé et qui répond à dans la
crise aux préoccupations particulières
que vivent les plus jeunes d'entre nous
de toute façon est une bonne chose
alors nous la cfe cgc on a quand même
j'allais dire des préventions par
rapport à la prime à l'embauché qu'on
croit être assez mal employé c'est à
dire qu'en fait elle sollicite beaucoup
trop les effets d'aubaine
nous on le dit depuis le début ce sont
des dispositifs très coûteux et qui sont
financés sur l'argent public et qui en
fait sont assez peu efficace parce que
quand une entreprise n'embauchent que si
elle a besoin et c'est pas une prime qui
fait faire une embauche d'autant que en
plus pour nous c'est un peu un abus la
prime peut être versés pour des
embauches qui ne sont pas en cdi mais
qui sont en cdd une certaine longueur
donc on a des réserves sur le dispositif
par ailleurs on soutient le dispositif
qui consiste à aider par une prime
l'embauché d'un alternant parce que
c'est vrai le dispositif d'apprentissage
est un dispositif on le sait très
qualitatif et qui permet de s'insérer
beaucoup mieux dans l'emploi on a des
données objectives des statistiques qui
ne le prouve ce qu'on souhaite quand
même c'est qu'on regarde dans les mois
qui viennent en vérité l'année prochaine
si ça n'a pas eu un effet de déflation
sur la capacité de cette formation
d'excellence donc la formation par
alternance et quel qu'en soit le niveau
6 a pas eu un effet un peu contre
productif sur l'insertion dans l'emploi
aujourd'hui on peut pas préjuger moi je
pense qu'il faut se satisfaire du fait
que nous avons tenues en 2020 des
niveaux d'entrée en apprentissage très
élevé au delà même des objectifs il faut
probablement le reproduire en 2021
mais il faut être attentif à l'impact
sur le marché de l'emploi justement
l'impact sur le marché de l'emploi il
est évidemment spa vous que je vais la
prendre très particulier en ce moment
est ce qu'on peut vraiment sûr
tabler sur des réformes structurelles
dans le fond aujourd'hui et vous lisiez
les aides sont satisfaisantes mais pas
qu'eux mais attend le choix aujourd'hui
de délivrer des tout simplement d aide
et de ne pas faire de réformes trop
profond et si j'ose dire écoutez c'est
effectivement la question clé moi je
vous suis là dessus moi je vais vous
redire ce que j'ai dit au premier
ministre et au gouvernement
le choix qui a été fait en france de
soutenir l'activité à travers le chômage
partiel est un choix important courageux
il fallait le faire il faut se rappeler
que on ne va donner un chiffre
pour 2020 un coût total du chômage
partiel de l'ordre de 27 millions
d'euros 27 milliards d'euros
donc c'est extrêmement important il faut
rappeler que sur ces 27 milliards can à
un tiers qui sont financés par l'unedic
c'est à dire par les cotisations sur les
salaires donc par l'ensemble de la
collectivité des salariés et pour deux
tiers par l'impôt donc c'est quelque
chose qu'il fallait faire nous nous
soutenons ce dispositif en même temps
que nous soutenons ce qu'on appelle la
pld c'est à dire le moyen pour les
entreprises de négocier des accords qui
vont mettre en place le chômage partiel
et la formation qui va avec tout ça il
nous semble ça nous semble être une
bonne politique qui normalement nous met
dans une meilleure situation au moment
du redémarrage de l'économie bien sûr on
souhaite tous que les conditions
actuelles bien ne seront que de courte
durée désormais qu'on pourra redémarrer
l'économie j'entends par là tous les
établissements toutes les entreprises
qui sont fermées par décret et bien sûr
le commerce la restauration la culture
les salles de sport etc
donc c'est bien de ça qu'il s'agit et il
est très clair que ces dispositifs là
sont des dispositifs utiles et qu'il
fallait faire il fallait une certaine
façon un peu de courage politique pour
le faire par contre je termine là dessus
il ya un sujet puisqu'on parle beaucoup
de la sortie crise qui pour nous est
absolument centrale et dont on ne peut
pas faire l'économie dans l'examen c'est
celui du partage de la valeur
c'est celui de la gouvernance des
entreprises et à ce titre s'il faut me
donner les 30 secondes
je pense qu'aujourd'hui 15 mars 2021 est
une date à retenir puisque je les ai dit
au ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
j'ai dit ben écoutez je veux partager
votre peine parce que ce sur quoi ce que
vous aviez fait comme un symbole de loi
pacte c'est à dire l'entreprise a
mission a été sacrément battue en brèche
duy 1 puisque le pdg de danone qui avait
transformé son entreprise en entreprise
a mis la mission est bien vient d'être
limogé
il n'ya pas d'autre mot par ses
actionnaires parce qu'il considère que
l'entreprise ne génèrent pas
suffisamment de profits pour ses
actionnaires
donc ce problème là il est central il
est posé devant nous et tant qu'on
n'aura pas regarder cette question là on
aura énormément de mal à avancer dans la
réforme de la société de l'économie de
ce qui est pour nous absolument central
c'est-à-dire la question de
l'élaboration de la valeur et de son
partage françois om-lille plus
globalement presque un an jour pour jour
après le premier confinement on voit
malheureusement à la lumière des
chiffres qu'on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge pour plagier le premier
ministre quelle suite pour le quoi qu'il
en coûte à la fin il faudra bien payer
et rembourser
oui bien sûr vous savez aujourd'hui ils
ceux qui ont payé beaucoup c'est les
français en fait un cd français qui ont
payé ce sont les jeunes qui payent
beaucoup
il faudra s'en souvenir nous avons tous
une dette vis à vis des jeunes les
jeunes de 20 ans qui passe le meilleur
de leur vie pour certains enfermés dans
leur chambre qui ne peuvent pas aller en
cours
les jeunes de 20 ans et un peu plus un
peu moins qu'ils ne trouvent pas du
travail comme normalement il devrait en
trouver
nous avons une dette vis-à-vis d'eux ils
ce sont les français qui ont financé le
chômage partiel c'est l'impôt se sont
pas beaucoup les bénéfices des
entreprises il me semble alors on vient
nous rappeler effectivement que l'année
2020 est une année dans lequel les
marges les entreprises ont été très très
faible certes
effectivement j'ai pas beaucoup entendu
que les actionnaires qui soi-disant
prennent tant de risques
raison pour laquelle il faudrait temps
les rémunérer mais lg pas beaucoup vu
les actionnaires venir faire des
déclarations devant la presse pour dire
eh bien cette année je vais mettre à
contribution une partie de mon bénéfice
pour le redonner au profit des
entreprises et des salariés pour pouvoir
affronter la crise peut-être que ça
c'est un sujet aussi qu on pourrait
discuter ensemble ouais merci françois
aux mairies le président de la cfe cgc
d'avoir été
avec non direct sur rt france merci à
vous